gestern kam es ja in beirut auch zu
extremen unruhen wie heißt du diese
erlebt ja das ist richtig
nach der gewalt gewesen zirka 20.000
menschen haben im stadtzentrum von
beirut haben uns gehört da kam es dann
zu heftigen ausschreitungen zu brutalen
straßenschlachten mit der polizei
da hat nicht einfach die gesamte und auf
die regierung entladen ist die
steinigung häuser haben gebrannt
demonstranten regierungsgebäude besetzt
und die polizei ist mit größter
brutalität dagegen vorgegangen wir haben
sehr viele demonstranten gesehen in der
menschenmenge die uns mit stark
blutenden wunden entgegen gekommen sind
und außerdem tränengasgranaten in die
menge geschossen wir haben eine anzeige
wegen der immer wieder granaten auf
einmal in die menge geschossen hat diese
granaten in der menschenmasse auch
explodiert und naja also sehr unschöne
szenen gewesen
leider müssen wir halt auch sagen dass
scharf geschossen wurde ein junger
polizist hat bei diesen ausschreitungen
in seinem leben verloren
der von einer kugel getroffen worden die
sein kollege abgefeuert hat soll ein
querschläger gewesen sein der an einer
mauer abbezahlt ist und ihn tödlich am
kopf verletzt auch die armee ist im
einsatz gewesen und hat die polizei bei
diesen ausschreitungen unterstützen auch
da kam es am späten abend unschönen
szenen als die soldaten die schwer
verletzten demonstranten daran gehindert
haben wie in den krankenhäusern
medizinische hilfe zu holen
wie ist denn die situation in beirut
jetzt na ja da haben die aufbauarbeiten
gehen weiterhin das gleiche bild das ich
uns schon seit tagen gebietet viele
junge menschen sind in den versperrten
strassen unterlegten jahren stellen
dabei die haben wesen dabei und die
packen hier an und räumen wieder auf die
verlassen sich darauf dass die regierung
ihnen hilft und das ist etwas sehr
schönes man man spricht hier an jeder
ecke die hoffnung die libanesen begeben
sich auf die kämpfe auch wenn es
wahrscheinlich noch monate wenn nicht
sogar jahre dauern wird die stadt wieder
aufgebaut sind und dazu muss man auch
sagen packen hier an und das unter aller
gefährlich diese häuser stark
einsturzgefährdet immer wieder über
teile von interspar hofmann herab aber
das ist den menschen egal und ihr leben
wieder zurück sebastian pangl in beirut
vielen dank